et c'est pas parce que Raymond a une
aventure avec Cindy Lopes
[Applaudissements]
maintenant celui qui me
tire de vrais avec des dossiers récents
je demande à Siri des gens ils viennent
pour voir Touche pas à mon poste bien
sûr pour voir de la lessive comme ça
si vous voulez j'y vais moi Guillaume il
parle moi je peux y aller sur internet
il est beaucoup dans la télé-réalité
les gens connus tu vois beaucoup de gens
connus c'est quoi les sujets aujourd'hui
là
il a été loin dans ce qu'il était très
loin de la calomnie moi je dis des
choses vrai tu me tire dessus je te tire
dessus je veux qu'on parle de d'une
certaine manière
non pas du tout